when it comes to filing legal documents
things can get tricky sun inc the
sponsors of this next segment they are
here to help let's welcome to the show
seth nawazu and his wife dr cambriana
nuasa welcome you guys thank you thank
you for having us it's great to chat
with you guys uh so first off why did
you decide to start this company i
started a good company with my wife for
the purposes of trying to help people i
mean there's a need for legal services
there's a need for
legal nurse consulting services and i
think we have the professional
uh acumen to be able to move that needle
forward to help people you know get that
justice that they're in search for let's
break it down i'll start with you doctor
what are the services that you guys
provide well for my services i'm as a
legal nurse consultant i help businesses
that handle any type of medical claim
with reviewing medical records medical
records are in medical jargon no one can
understand yes go on
and then also i can also give my
recommendations for any expert witnesses
for cases so so if i get a bill from a
health care provider or someone here in
town and i am confused about what to do
i can come to you for the consultation
oh that's huge that's used absolutely
and seth what is your side of the
business so i i have the individuals and
businesses that need assistance with
legal document preparation or legal
research and i also have attorney
clients single member practitioners
medium-sized firms that like to
outsource it for certified paralegal
services so more ideally you know people
that want to self-represent themselves
they can articulate their argument in
court you know i'm that person that they
would want to deal with to help put
together those pleadings um if they are
looking to file like a bankruptcy or
they're looking to do any type of
landlord tenant matter they come see me
and you guys i love it too you're not
new to town you're doing this since 2008
2008 what's the back story in the name
sun inc sun inc is an acronym for my
name uh seth you see for noel to
incorporate it so it's an old to my name
and my parents would name me i love it
now someone's watching right now is
there something that we're doing
on our own that we should be coming to
see you guys for and getting that help
for i think from from the certified
paralegal perspective legal document
prepared perspective uh there are things
that you can
uh offset your costs make it more cost
effective to deal with us and i think if
you are trying to save money and you
don't necessarily have the money for an
attorney and you don't qualify for legal
aid you should come see me uh from
cambridge's perspective what would you
say i would definitely say
for any business that's dealing with any
type of medical claim do not interpret
medical records on your own unless
you've been trained to do so and you
have that training to do it which is
great absolutely because that stuff can
just be very very confusing correct what
about uh let's say a speeding ticket or
something like that and you get
someone's disappear from a judge is that
something that you could advise on well
i i don't advise and i don't represent
in court but say for instance they
needed to look up like a stature yes or
they needed to know like civil procedure
i can assist with that if they wanted me
to draft that pleading for whatever the
legal argument is
i can craft that under that at their
discretion i can craft that form on
their behalf i love that we need to talk
once this segment wraps up
you guys are fantastic it's such a
pleasure to have you here on the show i
really appreciate it appreciate it thank
you so much thank you so much
thanks to sonic for sponsoring this
segment call
973-932-6031 or visit
sunincorp.net for more and don't forget
you get a free consultation with the use
of the promo code las vegas now we will
be right back